john bolton thank you for joining me on
the show
glad to be with you thanks for having me
in recent weeks we've heard
president donald trump refuse to say
whether or not he'll accept the result
of the election whether he'll commit to
a peaceful transition of power
you know the man you worked closely with
him for nearly two years in the white
house
if he loses to joe biden will he concede
on the wednesday morning
and accept the result well i don't i
don't think that's likely and i don't
think he's going to leave
graciously at all you know i do think
there's a little bit of misunderstanding
in some of these questions about
what it means to accept the outcome of
the election and certainly
the president should say that
unequivocally
but that doesn't mean that you can't
contest the outcome of the election
through normal legal channels as uh
al gore did in 2000 in florida and i can
tell you i spent
31 days in florida in a thousand
it's an arduous process but but there is
room
for contesting an election especially
when the results are closed
uh that said i think the president
should be clear he believes in the
integrity
of the u.s electoral process and the
fact donald trump won't say that is very
troubling
in your book the room where it happened
you are scathing about donald trump you
suggest the president is childish
ignorant dishonest unfit for high office
you say he was fine with concentration
camps in china
you say he talked about executing
leakers and journalists in the u.s
and yet despite all of that you now say
you will not
be voting for joe biden next month
instead you say you're going to quote
write in the name of another republican
which makes no sense to me you say he's
all of these horrific things but then
you're okay with effectively helping him
get reelected
well i'm not effectively helping him get
re-elected i live in maryland joe biden
will carry maryland there's no question
about
it let me just give you the example of
george meaney the president of the afl
cio in 1972 for the first time in his
life
didn't vote for the democratic nominee
george mcgovern
but told richard nixon he wasn't going
to vote for him either so
you know it's uh i think it's something
that people do quite regularly in
american elections there's nothing
unusual about
but if you were in a swing state then
wisconsin
florida would you vote biden to stop
this man who you say is a threat to u.s
national security
no i would not vote for biden uh again
it's it's
you know you can have an election where
even if it meant to trump re-election
sorry even if it meant to trump
reelection you would not vote for biden
i don't think either one of them should
be president for different reasons
oh but one of them has to be this is
like i mean i interviewed jill stein in
2016 the same argument one of them will
be i'm just wondering who you would
prefer
out of the two one of them is going to
be the president one i don't prefer
either one look i understand the
argument you're making and in 2016
i bought it and i voted for trump uh and
i tried for 17 months to
uh to to make a difference but i'm not
going to vote for him for obvious
reasons
but philosophically i don't think biden
will bring the right policies for the
country
and i'm not going to endorse him okay in
your book i mean you make a lot of
accusations against donald trump trump
has uh denied those accusations
um of course donald trump lies and
misleads more than anyone else in public
life so you could
discount his denials and the quotes from
him in your book ring true
on the other hand you have george w bush
another republican president you worked
for
who was once quoted telling people i
don't consider bolton credible
your former cabinet colleague secretary
of state mike pompeo who you say in the
book took a dim
view of trump he says you're lying he
even calls you a traitor who are the
rest of us supposed to believe why
should we believe any of you
well look i'm happy to stake my
credibility against donald trump anytime
president bush was put off by some
criticism i made of his north korea
policy
and i think pompeo obviously doesn't
like the portrayal of him and the book
i tried as hard as i could to reflect
as accurately as i could what actually
happened and uh
i've i've put it out there if others
have other versions they're entirely
entitled to put theirs out there as well
did you ever think that your long
history in the conservative movement the
republican party would end
with a sitting conservative republican
secretary of state
calling you a traitor well i i don't
think my
uh role in the conservative movement or
the republican party is over
and i think mike pompeo wants
desperately to be president we'll see
whether that happens
um as i say donald trump of course has a
long history of telling lies
of baselessly attacking people who once
worked for him he has called you
an idiot a jerk a wacko a lowlife among
other choice insults
verbal abuse is the president's strong
suit of course but then again when he
says in response to you and your book
that you're a quote
war monger that all you quote wanted to
do is drop
bombs on everybody is he correct about
that because you backed the iraq war
you called for the assassination of
gaddafi you wanted a much bigger strike
on syria in 2018
you're on record calling for pre-emptive
strikes against both iran and north
korea
so i wonder is trump right about that
for once about his description of you
nbc is reporting today he's considering
giving a speech to pull more troops out
of afghanistan
something i'm guessing you oppose there
too
well your question is about as
simplistic as trump's criticisms
so i don't i don't think trump was right
in his characterization
of me nor are you and the uh 18 things
you've listed he each has a
complex history behind it which i'd be
happy to discuss
given the opportunity but i think i
think when you go after people using
bumper stickers you're going to have a
pretty simple-minded discussion
which i try and avoid so let's talk
about the
the complex issues you said you wanted
to discuss you say in your book
that unlike mike pompeo who had to
recant his support for the iraq war
during senate confirmation hearings you
didn't have to uh because you were not
confirmed by the senate as national
security advisor
and correct me if i'm wrong you don't
have any regrets you never have
apologized for the iraq war unlike a lot
of other former supporters of it like
joe biden
so what i'm wondering is all those
thousands of people who died in iraq all
of those innocent iraqi civilians men
women children
killed by us airstrikes some of them in
massacres at haditha mahmudiyah balad
none of those weigh on your conscience
none of those deaths ever keep you up at
night
you don't know what you're talking about
the iraq war
which was the period that lasted about
four weeks
and resulted in the overthrow of saddam
hussein
was a brilliant military victory by the
united states and other coalition forces
uh and that the removal of saddam
hussein from power
was the right idea at the time and it's
true today
where the united states made a mistake
and i've said this repeatedly
over the years was in the period
following the overthrow of saddam
hussein i do not think
we should have set up a coalition
provisional authority i think we should
have kept our troops in iraq for a lot
of reasons
but i think we should have turned
responsibility for the government over
to iraqis as soon as possible
you do not increase a people's political
maturity by making decisions for them
you increase their political maturity by
making them make decisions
for themselves so people talk about the
iraq wars though it started in 2003
and lasted until 2011 when obama
withdrew everybody
as if every single decision in that
eight-year period
followed inevitably unalterably from the
single decision to invade in 2003
and that's simply not right you say it's
simply not right but the reality is
hundreds of thousands of iraqis died
there was torture millions of refugees
and that did follow
from the decision by george w bush dick
cheney and others in the administration
like yourself to invade iraq hundreds of
thousands of people died and just to go
back to my question which you didn't
answer
do those deaths never do those deaths
never weigh on your conscience
was my question which you didn't answer
no i did answer and i'll answer it again
since you didn't seem to listen to it
the the fact was after the overthrow of
saddam hussein
a number of decisions could have been
made in different ways
i don't believe in u.s participation
in nation-building i think nations have
to build
themselves and had the united states
followed through with that approach
rather than
engaging in extensive nation building
the outcome i think
could well have been very different but
delays
what happened in iraq on the single
decision to overthrow saddam hussein
is historically completely wrong but no
one's doing that they're pointing to the
war and the invasion and the occupation
you're trying to disconnect the
occupation
with respect john bolton you weren't you
weren't a pundit on fox news then you
were in government i don't remember you
quitting
in objection to the occupation and the
fact is that occupation
that occupation let me just finish my
question you come back in that
occupation produced
thousands of dead torture refugees uh
richard clark who was white house
counterterrorism
tsar at the time uh shortly after 9 11
called
war crimes kofi annan called the war
illegal i just wondered do you ever
worry that
you know people have tried to do
citizens arrests on you in the past do
you ever worry
you may have to face a court to answer
for that war on that occupation
for the war crimes that happened back
then uh
of course not because what you're saying
is completely ludicrous and those who
made those kinds of criticisms
are not reflecting what actually
happened
uh and i made clear in my first book
surrender is not an option that i was
largely excluded from
actual decision making on iraq by colin
powell
because he felt i had a different point
of view than he did
so my my observations here are from
somebody who
had a pretty good idea what was going on
inside
uh didn't agree with it but didn't have
much influence over policy i'm not
trying to
duck the issue but but you're making a
grievous factual error when you
attribute
everything that came after the overthrow
of saddam
to the u.s decision to do that that's
called the post hoc ergo propter hawk
fallacy
look it up okay while i look it up let
me just ask you that question one more
time you keep saying i'm not listening
to you
but i've asked twice i'll ask you one
third time because i want to talk about
iran and the nuclear deal i know you
have strong views there
very quickly on iraq you have no regrets
about the thousands of iraqis who died
in iraq after the invasion they never
bother you never keep you up at night
never away on your conscience
i didn't say that at all and what i'm
saying is that the
the actual casualties and the overthrow
of saddam hussein
i understand that but you're still not
answering the question it's a very
simple question yes or no do they weigh
on your conscience it's not
because you cannot attribute it causely
to the u.s
invasion simply because any any
you're you're you're you're making
assumptions
uh about things i'm asking a very simple
question for you to answer whether they
weigh on your conscience you don't seem
to want to answer it
you're not letting me say no and we'll
move on so i can't explain it
because the interview is just about over
the fact is
that much of the dissension and much of
the
casualties that happened inside iraq
after saddam was overthrown were caused
by iran
by its intervention it's arming and
training of shia militia by its
fostering
uh increased sectarian strife that
eventually broke the country apart
okay you mentioned iran let's just ask
about the iran deal you described in
your book how you pushed to get trump to
withdraw from the nuclear deal
you said it was your happiest moment as
a member of the trump administration
when he did that in may 2018. here's the
thing according to the iaea
iran had 100 kilograms of enriched
uranium at the start of the trump
presidency and while the deal was in
place
today the iaea says iran has 2 000
kilograms
of enriched uranium 20 times as much how
can you say that is anything other than
a failure of the trump bolton policy on
iran
well it it wasn't the implementation of
the bolton policy
but i can tell you that the iaea has
very limited information about what's
going on inside iran it knows what
iran has declared it and it doesn't know
anything else
the fact is that iran never made a
strategic decision to give up its
nuclear weapons
program or its ballistic missile program
uh
the decision by the trump administration
to withdraw from the deal and reimpose
u.s sanctions
has put enormous pressure on iran
unfortunately
not yet enough but iran under its
present leadership
is never voluntarily going to give up
nuclear weapons and it didn't
under the 2015 deal either it was a
failed deal
that allowed that's not what the iaea
says that's not what the inspectors say
they say 20 times as much now outside of
the deal
as in the deal ieee is not an espionage
agency
it knows what people declare to it and
it doesn't know much else
okay let me ask you this uh can i ask
how much of your antipathy
uh and your criticism towards iran i
know you've been very
critical of iran over 15 years
nearly up let me ask you this how much
of your antipathy towards iran
is to do with geopolitics how much of it
has to do with the fact that you've had
a long association
with a group called the mek which was
once a terrorist group banned by the
state department
while you work there you don't mention
it in your book
i looked in your book there's no mention
of the mek i think you took tens of
thousands of dollars for several
speeches just wondering how much that
influences your policy on iran
you know that i took tens of thousands
of dollars from speeches for speeches at
liberal universities in the united
states
uh this is uh this is this is really
about as low as it gets the the fact is
that hillary clinton
perhaps someone you support took the mek
off the u.s list of terrorist
organizations how about that
i speak what i yeah she took she took it
off in 2012 you were speaking with them
in 2010 when they were still a banned
group
yeah now look that that that you're just
simply wrong on your facts on this
no you were there in paris in 2010
speaking at the mek rally
when they were still a banned terrorist
group according to the state department
that's
my opinion nobody buys my opinion and
you can ignore that if you want i'm very
comfortable i have never said
anything other than what i believe and
we are now sir
20 minutes into this interview which you
said was for 15.
i believe it's 15 minutes i've got a
timer going off in my ear so we have one
last question before you go and i
appreciate your time
it's 20 minutes go ahead very last
question last question i do appreciate
you taking time out for this
one last question you say uh you know
you said in um
uh you said earlier that you know
there's lots of complex questions around
the war
trump's description is too simplistic as
a war monger but you are someone
associated with a hawkish foreign policy
and yet when the opportunity came for
you to personally serve in uniform in
vietnam in 1969
you joined the maryland national guard
instead you wrote in your college
reunion book
i had no desire to die in a southeast
asian rice paddy
i wonder how i wonder how you justify
that supporting all these wars that send
americans out to die
but you never chose to go out and fight
yourself
yeah do you have the complete quotation
uh i think i do i can do you want the
complete quotation let me pull it
you say let me just get it for you you
say um
well there's a couple of we've spoken
about it in two different books in your
yale reunion book you said i confess i
had no desire to die in a southeast
asian rice paddy
i considered the war in vietnam already
lost that's not the complete quotation
i'll read you the complete quotation
okay i best i confess that i had no
desire to die
in a southeast asia rice paddy when i
knew
full well that american public opinion
generally
and the vast if not virtually unanimous
opinion
of the yale class of 1970 was to give
that rice paddy back to the communist
who would
have killed me trying to take it away
from him
that's the complete quotation which you
didn't have and is typical of the rest
of the research
of this interview which really is but
you did say i have no desire to die in
vietnam even though 9 000 troops did die
after that moment after 1917.
when i'm not interrupted i speak in
complete sentences which i have just
done